obi-wan that's the name I've not heard
in a long time so I'm going to talk
about Star Wars in quite a while so
let's get to that and it's some good
news this time because last big Star
Wars news that happened was all the
stuff going on with the Han Solo movie
and yeah this I think this is better
news than that so the report is and
hopefully it hasn't been refuted but
i'ma put this video out but the report
is is that they are finally moving
forward with an obi-wan Kenobi solo film
this would be set between the prequels
and the original episode for a new hope
or at least that's the presumption so I
guess I mean really when else would you
said unless you're going to do it all we
want at like age 10 and god nobody wants
that so there's your sweet spot and so
not only is this apparently in the works
and honestly it's been rumored for a
very long time with no confirmation ever
coming from Lucasfilm on it but the big
word is that they have a director
attached to it and it's the guy who
directed Billy Elliot yeah so apparently
Lucasfilm is in talks with if have not
already tapped Steven Daltry of all
people to not only direct the film but
to help get the script and story into a
shape that they'll be ready to move
forward on and that is a slightly odd
pic I mean there's nothing in his in his
resume that screams you know Star Wars
or genre stuff in general I mean to be
fair that you know I don't want to
pigeonhole the guy I don't know what his
interests are aside from the movies that
he's done but he's never really done
anything with a particularly fantastical
bent to it like that Billy Ellie is
probably the best-known thing he's done
now I have to be upfront about the fact
I've actually never seen a movie this
guy's directed because he specializes in
films that just aren't for me and I'm
sure they're fine they're just it's not
the kind of stuff I tend to gravitate
towards so I actually haven't seen
anything the man's ever made
however given know the pedigree looking
at it his stuff does tend to get
nominations for stuff I mean Billy
Elliot especially has a heck of a legacy
to it so I mean I certainly would not
presume that he's a bad director or a
bad storyteller seems to have some
skills just again it initially seems
like an odd pick except that you got to
think about it Kenneth Branagh was an
odd pick to Thor but then again again if
you thought about you know the
Shakespearean operatic self it that fit
kind of made sense so in reality I can
think of as like maybe behind all of the
sort of you know serious-minded the
Oscar bait kind of movies this guy was
making that his in his own personal
passion he really liked Star Wars and
that I just never entered it into his
work before I don't know but that's
that's kind of the only thing I can come
up with but regardless of whether or not
he's a genre guy which clearly he's not
at least in terms of his resume he is an
established filmmaker with a good solid
track record and I think Lucasfilm is
learning from the debacle that has gone
on with the Han Solo movie which is that
if they're going to get a director who
is somebody with vision to bring them in
early in the process so that they are
working on the story and they are
putting the script into a shape that
everybody is agreeing on because I think
a big part of where everything went off
the way off the rails with the Han Solo
movie is they got Lord and Miller in to
work on a script that was already done
and these are guys who are you there
they're not real I mean they're
directors for hire insofar as they've
just gotten attached to various stuff
but they've also been allowed to shape
the story of those things and they're
not guys you can just throw on a script
and go do that script so I think
Lucasfilm is wise and up to the beg like
okay if we're getting visionary people
if we're not doing Marvel's current
thing which is to largely get people
from TV or people who are just going to
more or less work with the very specific
set of pieces we give them then we need
to get them in early enough in the
process that they can feel that they've
helped shape this movie and it's early
enough that we as a studio are still
comfortable with what they're doing so
that approach I think is probably
partially informed by what went on with
Han Solo even if the specific pick of
this director probably
he has nothing to do with that but I
also want to adjust the general concept
so open all Konami movie it's about
freakin time
I actually was stunned that this hasn't
been announced before this I mean
especially in terms of the fact of they
after the Josh Trank Boba Fett thing God
completely can and they assign no one
new to that so it was clear they weren't
picking up the pieces of above effect
project and they still was telling you
no talk of this other nebulas frog that
they wouldn't name and everyone always
kind of assumed it was obi-wan Kenobi I
mean it's the obvious thing to do and I
think it much like in the case of rogue
one it's a chance to tell a different
kind of story which is I before it's
what I want out of the spin-offs in
terms of these things you can tell
basically a Western you're practically a
samurai movie you go small-scale you
keep it contained to Tatooine you have
him just dealing with a very localized
menace it wouldn't even have to cost
that much you shoot in the desert use
practical creature effects and you
wouldn't aggregor has been saying for
years that he'd be happy to come back
and play the part again
why has this taken so long I'm sure
there's a lot of other going if you just
listen to the fans we could have already
had this movie by now except that I
actually tend to be of the mind that I
think one of the most dangerous things
that a creative entity can do is to
listen excessively to the fans because
fans we may know what we want but a lot
of times what we want isn't good for us
and sometimes to be frank what fans
really really want is just a flat-out
bad idea there's a lot of fans that want
the x-men in the MCU I already did a
video on why I think that's a bad idea
there were a lot of fans who after
prometheus were like go back to doing
just a lian's again and they didn't I
don't think that was a good idea either
I mean you shouldn't ignore the fans you
definitely shouldn't think them for
granted don't show them contempt but be
careful about fans dictating what you do
so on that level I I guess I'm a little
bit more forgiving of the fact that it
did take them this long because it was
the thing that all the fans were going
just do this and I think you should as a
creative entity and I know
Lucasfilm is a corporation it's all
about money cetera but they're still
putting out a creative product
they if that's what you do you need to
be careful about just going oh we'll do
what the fans want because we can be
dumb and we can be loud as we're dumb
but this is a fan idea that I think is a
good fan idea this really is kind of a
duh and while the attachment of Stephen
dollar doesn't immediately make a ton of
sense to me I'm really curious to see
what he's going to bring to this I mean
he's he's so not the guy that I would
think for this and yet is clearly a guy
with talent it makes me go I'm really
curious about what a guy like that is
going to bring to a project like this so
bring it on let's get going lockdown you
and McGregor now and make sure that's
all in place and let's move this thing
forward I want to see that what's next
on this and I I do hope it works because
and more than that I hope it goes
smoothly because if the Han Solo movie
doesn't manage to pull a rogue one it
managed to be good despite a very rough
and bumpy road getting there Lucasfilm
might decide that these movies aren't
worth the bother because so far first
with rogue one and again I like the
finished product of road one but it had
a heck of a development in going along
the way and now with the Han Solo movie
did the production on these things has
not been smooth and if they if the
obi-wan movie which again is the
slam-dunk no duh why wouldn't you do
that first move to make if that doesn't
go off smoothly either Lucasfilm may go
okay look guys we are making a profit
off these but these are turning to a big
headache let's just stick to the main
ones and maybe this is greedy Utley I
don't want that as long as the spin-offs
can have a distinctly different feel
from the made numbered saga I want them
to keep trying because I I want
something like a Western or a samurai
style movie with obi-wan Kenobi that's
going to have this more isolated lone
hero feel and as opposed to the epic
scale I want these different kinds of
stories and Star Wars for as long as
Disney as well Disney and Lucasfilm are
willing to make them so I hope this one
goes smoothly so that they'll be willing
to keep trying that experiment and for
as long as as we keep going I suppose so
those are my thoughts on that news what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down in the comment
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter right
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]